il est vrai que le petit benjamin
quel âge il a hélas six mois ouais c'est
vrai qu'on a déjà coupé quatre fois les
cheveux je vais défiler comme ces
monstres mais moi je les peurs série 1
mais lui il a des cheveux c'est
monstrueux jamais vu ça donc c'est sûr
qu'il a toi un vrai ouais il présente
même s'il était noir il sera à moi ouais
parce que c'est des fois dans les
maternités on les mélange
ouais ben non je crois pas là je crois
pas qu'ils aient pu mélanger regarde ah
ouais c'est la vie est un long fleuve
tranquille
ben oui à peu près alice et un bébé
heureux
elle a presque l'air contente d'être un
bébé prototype après sa naissance il ya
quatre mois sa mère a reçu une offre
surprenante
on m'a proposé deux dates où est mon
bébé on m'a bien fait comprendre que
c'était
expérimental mais que savait rien de
dangereux avec le tatouage suis sûr car
cela n'est pas toujours évident
aujourd'hui on identifie les nouveau nés
avec de simples bracelet juste après
l'accouchement un premier bracelet a
fixé au poignet du bébé un second à
celui de la mère tous deux portent un
même numéro et selon la maternité
l'heure et la date de la naissance
un procédé qui n'est pas sans faille
ainsi après leur sortie de la clinique
de cavaillon les époux ben ali urt une
mauvaise surprise bout d'une semaine on
a reçu un coup de fil de la maternité
comme quoi finalement il n'était plus
tout à fait sûr que ça notre enfant
tombé au moment du bain on n'a jamais eu
d'explication claire c'est le dernier
cas connus de substitution d'enfants on
compte en moyenne un échange déclaré
parents des cas certes rarissime mais
source de tels drames que le ministère
de la santé a demandé un institut
pasteur un système infaillible
d'identification une sorte de tatouage
l'opération se fait en deux temps un
numéro dessiné par de fines aiguilles
est inscrit dans la peau les aiguilles
sont enduites d'une solution incolore le
monoxyde al seconde phase le numéro
apparaît lorsqu'on frotte la peau avec
une autre solution le bim hawks inhalent
qu'on n'a pas utilisé les produits
traditionnels comme l'encré tatouages
parce qu'on ne voulait pas qu'il y ait
de problèmes de toxicité pour l'enfant
et donc on a utilisé ces deux systèmes
de produits chimiques révélateur et
produits incolore le tatouage s'effacera
progressivement au bout de cinq mois ce
procédé devrait être lancée en janvier
93 mais ils rencontrent déjà la
désapprobation d'un comité d'éthique
opposé au tatouage pour humains un
problème qui n'a pas l'air pourtant
d'embarrasser certaines futures mamans
quoi qu'elle discute déjà le graphisme
du tatouage
je préférais pouvoir dessiner le avoir
le choix du dessin c'est possible
moi je peux aller chercher très loin
jamais l'émission sur l'amour j'ai
entouré de cupidon je ferai un petit
cupidon avec une flèche sur la joue
gauche
on dirait que ça furoncle ne s'apprend
pas là les gens quand ils viendront
devant la clinique des tatouages pour
identifier les niveaux les s de l'info s
de l'intox
alors toi à l'oreille ne pas tu crois
moi je suis un texte parce que quand
vous avez fait votre expérience alors
j'ai mis sur un bras d'adulte et pas sur
un bras de bébé alors c'était un brave
bébés non non ah bon ouais c'est sûr
ouais c'est ce qu'on appelle un brin
enfants moi j'ai le sexe comme un enfant
de deux ans comme saint jacques c'est à
toi de jouer ce coup ci la foule même si
je pense pas que ce soit effectif se
passera mais mon avis c'est de l'info
herbert tu di donato de l'intox son
époux de philippe guérin vas-y mon fils
bravo ces deux graphiques ont tenté
encore une autre c'est de l'intox trille
or
un commentaire à faire mon petit
philippe whittier riche et très heureux
que ce soir tu me demande de faire un
commentaire sur ce reportage
patrick patrick sébastien oui ce que tu
peux me regarder de la lah vraiment là
oui je te regarde m'habitue voilà je
voudrais savoir où exactement
tu es né et quelle date je suis né le 14
en 1953 à brive
même le même jour que moi non la même
clinique
si si je fais pour que mon âge on a tous
les deux étaient mis au monde par les
docteurs pochtron et il s'est trompé
patrick a bon patrick oui tu aimais moi
et je suis toi tu es un imitateur
patrick tu m'as pris ma place
le point je peux
correction de ne rien rater de il a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux